the ideas that you get though where they
were they coming from are they channel
tease around I know that sounds really
like cliche but do you ever think of an
idea and turns out it's a real story
somewhere it just hadn't happened yet um
it's really weird but yeah I also have
ideas that like movie ideas don't come
to me as an idea I have like a flash and
I see the entire movie and so like I
know every single beat of that movie
like it'll like a flash in my mind and
I'm like so this scene happens in this
scene happens I know the full story when
the idea comes I know the entire story
it's not like well what if this happened
and then that happened like I know the
entire story and like I knew every
single scene in every single moment I
even saw shots in my head for some of my
movies that like right when I had the
idea and it just comes in flashes it's
it's really weird I used to I used to
say I think because I'm a Pisces I used
to say that like when I would take baths
being submerged in water made me think
of ideas I always loved water I like
swimming all that stuff also really
creepy that I believe in that because my
favorite food is sushi so like I like
eating fish which is weird but uh I
think finding that like that Zen moment
and then when I clear my mind and I
think if nothing something fills it with
like some random idea and I mean that
that became very useful because when I
got hired to write 13 13 13 for asylum I
was given three days to write that
script a hundred and twenty page script
I was given three days and then I was
given one day to do the rewrite and I
went into production the next day so
that was crazy I was given three days to
write a feature length script and the
movie just came to me in a flash and
then suddenly it became about people
being born on leap year being completely
crazy and I literally like SAT there and
wrote non-stop locked myself in the room
and just did it and it just I knew every
scene I knew what was happening and I
even
knew who I was going to cast in the
movie and I ended up casting him and I
put the guy wrote the characters towards
who they'd be and I wrote a character
for one of my friends that it was like
the perfect role for him and I think
it's the best role he's done where were
you when that flash came to you from um
physically interestingly enough I was uh
when that when that flash came to me I
was actually on the phone and they were
like hey we're hiring you to do this but
we want you to pitch the idea first and
I'm on the phone and I go pitch the idea
first and then like yeah the title of
the movie is going to be 13 13 13 I was
like well this is what happens and I
like explained the whole thing and
they're like okay well write it out and
I wrote it out and then boom but you
know I had to do like a treatment first
they approved the treatment and then all
in three days it was crazy but yeah it
literally came in a flash and my pure
joy came to me when I was taking a bath
and that's why in the movie he's he's
merged in water he keeps taking baths in
the movie to like think it's because
that's that's where the movie came to me
to Jennifer came to me I just taken a
shower and I was sitting like talking
with with Chuck who was the lead actor
and he was like all like being mopey at
the time because he was like you know
blah blah blah i saw him being mopey and
I was like wait hold on Chuck can you
say this and then I like filmed the
first scene of the movie right there I
like was like say this and like the
first scene was entirely improv but I
told him to say something and then I was
like it works like it plays really well
and then I went and wrote the rest of it
and I was like you know just just say
these things and and it worked perfectly
and that first scene of the movie is
still in it we filmed that before we
filmed everything else we filmed
everything else that
a little bit later but like I think like
two three weeks later but it was that's
why I talked about in the commentary
there's beard continuity on me because
my beard keeps like growing and
shrinking but that's why I wrote in
scenes where I'm shaving in the movie so
it looks like oh well time is past he's
shaving and then it grows back later
because it's like it keeps saying and I
have things going like this many days
later this many days later so it like
works with the movie but I wrote that in
it came in like flashes because I was
like okay this is what's going to happen
the ideas for these films do they come
to you in a flash and you find out that
actually that story already exists in
real life because it's a real thing
that's out there in the world or it
comes it happens later like it was a
precognitive yeah I mean yeah exactly
like with hate crime I was on my way to
showing of my movie my pure joy in
Oklahoma and we stopped off at a bar I
was on a fake idea I was 19 years old we
stopped off at a bar in Amarillo Texas
and wet that bar me and Jared Cohen who
ended up being my co-writer on hate
crime he was a producer of my pure joy
and then the producer of hate crime as
well we're at the bar together and we
get surrounded by neo-nazis and they go
you're a Geo ain't you boy ain't never
seen a Jew before where your horns at
Jew boy and they're like hassling us you
know tatted up skinheads being like
really you know aggressive and stuff and
one of them's like look at this I got a
Hitler mustache and he has like a
mustache right here tattooed on his
finger that made it into the movie in
hate crime because while this is going
on and the people who run the bar are
telling us we got to leave while this is
going on in my head I'm suddenly like
this is a movie what's the movie it's
it's a it's a home invasion it's a home
invasion and then it comes in a flash
and I see everything I saw i saw that
shot in the movie where the character of
lindsey
running through the woods and he's
pointing a gun out the window towards
her and she's running through the woods
illuminated by a flashlight and she
disappears into the woods I saw that
shot and then I saw the shot of the
Hitler mustache I saw all these flashes
of different shots from the movie and
then all of those shots made it into the
movie I saw every single shot and then
we sat down and while we were driving we
took shifts on who was writing me and
him and we wrote it on our way to
Oklahoma and on our way back and then we
started making the movie hate crime
which ended up being the movie I was I
guess most known for for right now it's
the one I did it one like tons of awards
and played film festivals around the
world
you